let's do a few audience questions why
don't we to wrap up the week now in
December Allison wrote in saying hey
David why can't Donald Trump just take
criticism in a more reasonable way yeah
I've received a lot of emails about this
and you'll remember that Donald Trump
number one just sort of lost it on
Twitter after Mike Pence went to
Hamilton the musical and there were
there was a message it was a pretty
respectful message actually to pence
about some of the concerns of different
groups around the country including
actors in Hamilton the musical I don't
know why Donald Trump can't take
criticism I think part of it comes with
the reality that as a Manhattan
billionaire who has been basically seen
as the powerful and respected guy in the
room for most of his life even though he
sort of been goofed on in social media
since being The Apprentice host and all
of that stuff by the way how crazy is it
that we're talking about the
president-elect by saying you know the
guy that used to be the host of The
Apprentice it's it's interesting because
his sort of relationship to the people
that follow him is now totally different
you have not only close to the number of
people that voted for you having voted
for someone else you have millions more
people that voted for the other
candidate and they don't like a lot of
the things that he said and they don't
like a lot of the things that he said
he's going to do so I I think that it is
okay to mock someone who can't take
criticism particularly when it's someone
of Donald Trump's stature who has chosen
to not only run for president and he
should be aware of what it is that that
brings with it but also chosen to run an
incredibly offensive and insulting
campaign insulting all sorts of people
during debates during interviews on
social media I believe that that it is
absolutely legitimate to criticize Trump
for the reality that he seems to not be
able to take jokes and as many people
pointed out during the campaign when we
saw how Trump would react to criticism
from Rand
media outlets from I don't know actors
from all sorts of random people you
could barely handle debate moderators
how are we to believe that he is not
going to be played like a violin to use
a term now that I've used a couple of
times by somebody like Russian leader
Vladimir Putin I mean it completely is
relevant to his job as president that he
is so thin-skinned and it is abundantly
clear to me that that is not a critique
on style it is actually a substantive
critique because of what we know is
required to be President of the United
States so Allison why can't Trump take
criticism I think it's decades of being
groomed as the guy who is just in charge
and respected and the man essentially
and now being faced with the reality
that he's incompetent and saying foolish
and incompetent things about so many
different issues and people are reacting
to that and is it okay to criticize him
for that absolutely no doubt about it